hey guys what's up so much awesome game
of thrones news we have to dig through
we learned about a brand new book that's
coming at the end of the year that may
have tipped us off as to when winds of
winter is coming out in season seven
stuff so if you've been gone for a while
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss any Game
of Thrones videos and there is a new
round of the game of Thrones giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's from one of the enhanced
editions of the books so people are just
now learning about this but it's
actually a pretty big deal but it's all
about season seven of Game of Thrones
leading into a winds of winter relief
leading into another short stories set
in the game of Thrones universe so what
I'm going to do is explain what's going
on
when's the winter update and then talk
about what this other brand news story
inside the world of A Song of Ice and
Fire is going to be because a lot of
people feel like it's going to be part
of the fire in blood Targaryen history
book that George r Martin is making he's
got a warehouse of Targaryen material
that he's written for other books that's
been cut out there just waiting to be
included in this big Targaryen anthology
so the really big thing first people
have been pounding reddit the Watchers
everybody that follows Game of Thrones
book news has found out that George R
Martin is contributing to a short story
book that's being released at the end of
this year that's called the book of
swords the thing about this that's
really important for winds of winter is
the timing of the book release because
originally it was going to come out
sometime early in 2017 with the planned
release of winds of winter originally
they were going to release the winds of
winter book early in 2017 in the idea
that everyone has figured out is that
this short story just because it's not
quite as big a deal would ride on the
coattails of that release so in the way
the books feed the show the show feeds
the book release the bigger books feeds
the smaller books it's all one thing at
a time so I'll explain what this new
Targaryen stuff that he might be
including in this book is but it just
means that because Game of Thrones
season 7 is dropping late June they
don't have an exact date yet but all
signs
pointing towards late June just a couple
months based on the time they started
shooting there's a couple months after
when they would normally start shooting
it's all just a matter of playing the
day they started shooting about three or
so months later than they normally would
so the seasons going to come out three
months later than it normally would
which would be in April so now it's in
June so no worries it just means Game of
Thrones Season seven party happening all
summer but because when the winter has
been delayed in this new book is coming
out at the end of the year it just
points to a winds of winter release at
the end of the summer like a little
after Game of Thrones season seven and
before the winter starts so you just
have to imagine that from about the
middle of June all the way towards the
end of the year we'll just be dominated
by Game of Thrones material both the TV
show and the books then because their
shooting schedule is going to be similar
to season 7 the season 8 release will be
about the same so it will be quite as
bad as the wait between season 6 in
season 7 plus we'll have all this new
winds of winter short story Song of Ice
and Fire material to dig through you
have to imagine that there's an order of
magnitude more book material then there
is show material there might be 10 hours
of TV show in a normal season but
there's hundreds of hours worth of
material in one of the books so there is
so much Game of Thrones stuff happening
later this year to get excited about and
this is something I should really talk
about in another bonus video but Martin
has said that he will be including a
whole bunch of stuff in the new books
that they will never be able to do on
the TV show so people that are upset
that Stannis is dead on the TV show like
he has some big big twist that he's
teasing for winds of winter that they'd
never be able to do on the TV show so
he's like aha you killed my characters
that are still alive in the books I'm
going to do some stuff that you can
never get away with so for those that
are worried that the TV show will
eventually spoil the books there's a lot
of the books that will be completely
different from the TV show with a really
important book stuff for those of you
asking what's going on with winds of
winter the confirmed preview chapters
that he's either read from or released
the POV characters that we know about
are Iran Greyjoy the damp air
Arianne Martell who's not a
TV show character Arya Stark Barristan
Selmy may he rest in peace on the TV
show Sansa Stark Theon Greyjoy Tyrion
who he's actually previewed two chapters
from winter winter and then Victarion
Greyjoy
so lately he's also revealed that Cersei
is going to get a chapter bran Stark is
going to get a chapter in areo Hotah is
going to get a chapter two but because
he does cut out a lot of things when
he's editing books out some of those
people might get pushed to dream of
spring which is going to be the next
book after winds of winter so if you're
a TV show person who's new to the books
George R Martin will release samples of
chapters before the actual books are
done so when we get to the next book
when we're waiting for the Game of
Thrones spin-off to start there will be
lots of sample chapters from dream of
spring to tide us over so what I'll do
this year is I will do a separate video
for all the winds of winter preview
chapters because I will be doing book
videos when the books come out most of
my videos tend to be TV show videos just
because that's you know most of my
subscribers come from from the TV show
but there'll be lots of book stuff
happening later this year meanwhile the
new fire and blood Targaryen story the
reason for making this videos it sort of
led people to find out when winter
winter is probably coming out he's most
likely going to be material that he cut
out from the dance of the Dragons saga
that he's been writing novellas for so
if you haven't been reading the books
the dance of the Dragons is the story of
a Targaryen Civil War that he's
published a couple of smaller books
about so he cut out a bunch of material
for that the first one is the princess
in the Queen it's based on the real-life
War of the Roses in English history then
later he published another book that was
a prequel to that called the rogue
prince that was about Viserys the first
Targaryen leading into that conflict so
a lot of you been asking about the Game
of Thrones spin-off maybe it will cover
this period in Targaryen history because
he's written so much about it and it
involved so much dragon writing it's
basically a period when a lot of the
Targaryen family were riding dragons
before they died off you have all the
craziness of a normal game of Thrones
story with the added bonus of crazy
dragon
writer battles because dragons were such
a big guilt as period it also deals with
dragon bonding it gets into more of the
lore of Game of Thrones that he hasn't
spelled out on the TV show or in the
main books yet either
in fact it's such a big deal that HBO
themselves produced some bonus content
like a feature rest detailing one of the
big encounters during this war so this
is actually narrated by the actor that
plays Oberyn Martell may he rest in
peace 14 days later the shadow blacker
than any passing clouds swept over
Harrenhal
Veigar had come at last and on her back
road one-eyed Prince naman he mocked the
demon for facing him alone
you have lived too long uncles and Damon
replied on that much we agree then the
old prince climbed stiffly onto the back
of his dragon caraxes but neglected to
fasten the chains secure rider to sun
the sun was close to setting when as one
the two dragons left into the sky Damon
took er axes up swiftly until they
disappeared into a bank of clouds vague
are older and slow ascended more
gradually up and up vague our sword
searching for Caracas suddenly
thunderman a shrieking caracas adobo on
vegard locked together the dragon
stumble toward the lake grasses just
closed up on vague ours neck but Vega
raked open Karachi's many and her teeth
ripped off a wing relay crushed up with
terrible speed then daemon targaryen who
had never fashioned his writing change
stood in his saddle he left from his
dragon to Amon and in his hand was dark
sister the veneerings word of a con
sister queen visenya as a nun one I
looked up in terror Damon ripped off his
nephews helm and drove the sword down
into his one remaining eye
so hard the point came out the back of
their young prince's throat half a
heartbeat later the Dragons struck the
leek sending up a gunk of water so high
that it was said to have been installed
at Harrenhal scraped our the Lake Borgne
with dragon blood and then was killed so
Martin is just written a lot about that
period in history that's why people
think the secret new book is going to be
about that but the other big theory is
that it's going to be new Duncan egg
from the fourth book he said he's going
to write after winds of winter comes out
if you don't know what that is
I've done videos about Duncan egg before
so we'll add links to that at the end of
this but there are only three books
right now he said he's going to continue
though so it'll be a much bigger story
but he's not going to do that till after
he delivers winds of winter that new
Duncan egg book is supposed to be called
the she-wolves of Winterfell so that'll
get you really excited that takes place
about a hundred years before the events
on the game of Thrones TV show - I know
everybody loves the Targaryen families
they have such a rich crazy history it's
so fun to read about but the history of
Winterfell and the stark family is also
super important - since the TV show
revealed that the night King was a First
Men I know a lot of you are asking if he
was part of the stark family that will
be my next bonus video that I'll post
this Sunday so it's going to be really
exciting
it is awesome is the idea of new stark
history is it's more likely that he's
just going to pull from the pile of his
Targaryen Edit and just include that as
one of these short stories so it's not
like he's writing new material instead
of doing wins a winter for this short
book it's just that he has all this
stuff that he is cut out to just like
copy and pasted into this new short
story book so I know now some of you are
like wait a minute
what is all this material that he's
cutting out we want to read this this is
great stuff he'll include all this in
separate books what will probably happen
like he's done in the past he always
publishes short novellas as he's working
on the big new Song of Ice and Fire
books leading into dream of spring like
well after winds of winter comes out
he'll probably find ways to release all
this
Jiro's that he's cut out in short blurbs
as he goes along so even if it takes
another six years to get that last game
of Thrones book he'll be releasing new
Game of Thrones book content every
single year he does that every year so
don't freak out too much but do get
really excited because there will be a
lot of new songs of Ice and Fire book
material coming out this year after
season seven drops in of course I'll be
giving away copies with a book right now
the enhanced editions are like the brand
new shiny thing so that's what the
giveaways are for but once the new books
come out that's what the giveaways will
be for but let me know what do you guys
think about the idea of him releasing
all this new Game of Thrones stuff at
the end of the year I feel like it's the
best possible news I mean people have
been waiting so long for new Song of Ice
and Fire in addition to waiting for TV
show stuff to drop but now it sounds
like it's all happening all at the same
time later this year it's going to be
crazy congratulations to the new Game of
Thrones giveaway winner Ruben Avalos you
win a copy of one of the enhanced
editions of the book please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's new Star Wars Episode 8 posting
tonight but new Game of Thrones on
Sunday while you wait for that you can
click here to learn about extra episodes
in season 8 like brand new stuff and you
can click here to learn all about duncan
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody
since i thought i'll see you in the next
video
Oh
you